فوق هذه الجبال ، إيران
نظام نجح في عزل العديد
من شعبه عن العالم الخارجي ،
لكن القصص المقلقة التي تروي بالتفصيل
أعمال الانتقام الوحشي التي تمارسها السلطة
ضد
المتظاهرين المناهضين للنظام بدأت
تتسرب
إلى المنطقة الكردية.  من
العراق لمحاولة معرفة المزيد
هذه هانا ليس اسمها الحقيقي.
امرأة إيرانية كردية تم تهريبها مؤخرًا
من إيران تخشى على حياتها
بعد خلعها وحرقها
للحجاب في الشوارع التي تم
اعتقالها واحتجازها من قبل
ضباط المخابرات الإيرانية التي اختاروها.
النساء اللواتي كن جميلات ومناسبات
لشهيتهن ، ثم يأخذ الضابط
إحداهن من الزنزانة إلى
غرفة خاصة أصغر يعتدون
عليهن جنسياً هناك ، هانا ليست مجرد
شاهد عيان ، لقد تعرضت للانتهاك أيضًا ، أشعر
بالخجل من الحديث عن هذا ، يمكنك ذلك  ما زلت أرى
ما شاهده الشرطي هنا على
رقبتي وهو أرجواني ولهذا السبب
أغطيها ففرض نفسه علي ثم
شجار ب  خرجت مع متظاهرة أخرى تسببت في هجوم
هانا على مهاجم
هانا وآخرون كانوا يسمعون صرخات
ويعتقدون أن امرأة تعرضت للاغتصاب في
غرفة الاستجواب ، رسمت هانا مخططًا
لمركز الشرطة وهي تتذكر ذلك
، وقدرت أن 70 إلى 80 رجلاً وامرأة
كانوا معًا في القاعة الرئيسية
تمكنت سي إن إن من الوصول إلى أربع غرف استجواب خاصة في غرف الاستجواب هذه ، وقالت
إنها تعرضت للاعتداء وتعرض آخرون
للاغتصاب.  الشهادة والتحدث إلى
عدد من المصادر يأتي نمط من
القمع إلى مراكز الشرطة
التي تستخدم كنقاط ترشيح لنقل
المتظاهرين من مكان إلى آخر في
كثير من الأحيان تترك العائلات لا تعرف
مكان احتجاز أحبائها.
240 شخصًا يعتقدون أنهم مفقودون
في هذا  متاهة مراكز الاحتجاز
تعتقد منظمات حقوق الإنسان أن
العدد أعلى في
الآلاف من الضحايا الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 14 عامًا. وكثير
منهم رجال يدعمون المتظاهرات إن
عقوبتهم شديدة مثل
النساء
اللواتي أحضرن أربعة رجال تعرضوا
للضرب وهم يصرخون بشدة.  تم إرسال
زنزانة أخرى وأحد الرجال الذين تعرضوا
للتعذيب إلى غرفة الانتظار حيث كنت
سألته عن كل هذا
الصراخ ، فقال إنهم يغتصبون الرجال
بناءً على شهادة شهود عادت سي إن إن
إلى موقع مقر استخبارات الجيش الإيراني.
هنا
بواسطة مترجم أرسل صبي يبلغ من العمر 17 عامًا لشبكة
CNN ملاحظة صوتية بعد سجنه
، نحجب اسمه وموقعه
حفاظًا على سلامته
عندما سمعني أحد حراس الأمن وأنا أتحدث
عن اغتصاب السجناء الآخرين
، بدأ يعذبني مرة أخرى ، حيث
قاموا بتعذيبهم واغتصابهم.  أنا من الخلف حتى
عندما زار السلطات
العنف الجنسي على متظاهرين اتهمت شخصيات النظام
المتظاهرات المتظاهرات
بالدعارة q  الرغبة في التعري
من حوادث العنف الجنسي
ضد المتظاهرين داخل
مرافق الاحتجاز الإيرانية ، حدث معظمها في
المناطق ذات الأغلبية الكردية إلى الغرب
من إيران ، وهي موطن لأقلية مضطهدة تاريخياً ، وهو ما
يثير القلق في بعض الحالات ، حيث
تم تصوير عمليات الاغتصاب واستخدامها لابتزاز
المتظاهرين لإسكاتهم.
[موسيقى]
كان هناك تصعيد حقيقي حيث
تكون المتظاهرات كما ترون
هنا يتعرضن للاعتداء الجنسي في كثير من الأحيان بشكل علني ،
لكن العنف ضد النساء مثل
الاحتجاجات لا يقتصر على المناطق الكردية ،
بل غالبًا ما يركزن على
الأماكن التي تشتد فيها الاحتجاجات
كما هو الحال هنا في العاصمة طهران ،
واحدة من هذه
القصص نموذجية تبلغ من العمر 20 عامًا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تشارك حبها للحيوانات وهذا ولكن
ليس أقله
في منشورات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي تظهر تحت
اسمها عباسي مثل العديد من النساء الشابات في
إيران اللواتي انتقدن النظام علنًا بعد
بدأت العملية على عكس معظمها من
دون إخفاء هويتها
، ولم يستغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً لقوات الأمن
العثور عليها واعتقالها اختفت عباسي
بعد فترة وجيزة من بدء المبلغين عن المخالفات في النشر
على مختلف منصات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي.شارك المسعفون
روايات شهود العيان
عما حدث لعباسي أولاً وقبل كل شيء قالوا
إن هناك عددًا قليلاً من الرجال المقربين
منها ولم يسمحوا لها  بعيدًا
عن أعينهم حتى أثناء
الفحص الطبي الخاص كانوا هناك
، كانت مريضي ، ذهبت إلى جانب سريرها
، لقد حلقوا شعرها
وكانت خائفة وترتجف
عندما دخلت لأول مرة ، قالوا إنه كان
نزيفًا في المستقيم بسبب الاغتصاب المتكرر
بملابس مدنية  أصر الرجال على أن
يكتب الطبيب أن الاغتصاب كان من
قبل اعتقالها ، ثم بعد
أن أصبحت هذه القضية واضحة للجميع ، قاموا
بتغيير السيناريو بالكامل
تم تأكيد تفاصيل هذه التسريبات
لشبكة CNN من قبل أحد المطلعين في
مستشفى الإمام علي حيث كان عباسي.
في بيان
قالت الحكومة إن عباسي عولجت من
مشاكل في الجهاز الهضمي
، وقال المسعفون الذين عالجوها إن هذا
غير صحيح
ينفي النظام الإيراني اغتصابها
متهماً إياها بقيادة الاحتجاجات ،
وهو ادعاء قد يجعلها تواجه
عقوبة الإعدام
في هذا المعبر الحدودي المزدحم عادة
بين العراق وإيران.
عقود استخدام
التعذيب الجنسي ضد الإيرانيين ويبدو
مرة أخرى أنه نمط مألوف
للعنف الجنسي تم نشره لفرض
تأكيد الوصاية الأخلاقية